Gott Herr Müller kann ich ihnen
irgendwie behilflich sein das wä sehr
nett sie haben doch einm diesen
trockenen Rotwein verkauft war ist da wo
sie mit so einer blond gefbten zuchtel
da mit so aufgespritz die
schlauchbotlippen da habe ich Ihnen ein
spritzigen Italiener verkauft na das war
schon früher aber war das in der Zeit wo
sie so getrunken haben zfen kom direkt
so weggissen bei dem fuel mein lieber
Scholli da waren sie schon ganz unten
her mülle ich sag nuralken unser
mädchenschreck Jahrgang 89 in der
praktischen 2 l Familienpackung aber sie
haben ja auch ausgeschaut damals
ausgeschaut ungepflet um nicht zu
sagen sichaschen
habarassenü
liebeninlichkeiten